Mathematically measure the perfect slice with
the protractor pizza cutter.
And wear it proudly around your neck using
the pizza pouch.
Because it’s episode 57 of LÜT.
Think before your drink resting your beverage
on a brain specimen coaster.
When stacked in the proper order these ten
slices give you a full brain that will send
your cerebellum into celebration.
Keep that cranially stimulation going by spreading
on some caffeinated peanut butter.
And then make your friends jelly by showing
off your Brick Box.
A monthly treasure trove of Lego sets, mini
figures and related brick products.
In case bricks in a box aren’t enough - the
EverBlock is a modular building block system
that allows you to build just about anything.
The come in different sizes, shapes and colors
and the website offers tips for furniture,
stage sets, room dividers and actual buildings.
If your stress level is building relieve the
pressure with this uhhhhh gourmet scented
donut stress ball.
Squeeze the delectable pastries that smell
like the real thing just donut put them in
your mouth.
Or your wooly mammoth dog costume.
Keep your hands abominably warm while wearing
these USB Yeti hand warmers.
With low or high warmth settings to keep your
paws toasty.
While you’re outside jotting down heavenly
observations into this Stargazing notebook.
If you’re puzzled by light in the sky allow
the Rubik’s cube lamp to puzzle the light
in your home.
The rechargeable light twists and turns just
like a real Rubik’s cube and connects to
a power source via USB.
See the sands of time fall magnetically through
the magnetic sand timer.
An ordinary hourglass filled with iron filings
that create a new unique sculpture every…time.
And if you enjoyed that pun give yourself
a high five.
A wind-up high five.
For those who prefer their magnets in the
form of spinning orbs - there’s the aptly
named spinning magnetic orbs.
The magnets are independent of the shell so
you can interact with them in a gamble-mounted
360 degree spherical way.
Play cards the undead way by dealing a deck
of zombie playing cards.
Which include spooky survival tips in case
of zombie attacks.
Attach some sushi to your sleepy face with
stuffed sushi handmade plush sushi pillows.
And if you sashimi wearing these shades and
need a bottle opened - I'll crack it open
using The Hook titanium bottle opening sunglasses.
Which you can store safely and majestically
on Perry The Carved Peacock Eyeglasses Holder.
Now hold onto your x-ray knee high socks.
Because this Jack Frost mask by Oneail FX
Studios is incredible.
There are actually a ton of amazing masks
on the website to make this the best Halloween
ever.
But wait.
There's a Halloween episode of LÜT for you
to watch right now over on DONG.
Abrand new channel for all the Vsauce shows
filled with things you can Do Online Now,
Guys.
So go check it out, Michael Jake and I all
have videos waiting for you - make sure you
subscribe to DONG.
And as always - thanks for watching.